I need you to be fierce yourself so that
you can inspire the ugly people to buy
themselves into gorgeousness listen to
the word fierce fierce what does it
saying to you I hear fear the worst
I really do fears
daring unexpected exhilarating that's
fierce can you be fierce
uh-huh yes yes we can certainly try
shame on your house wait wait firing you
is not my idea I promise I didn't be
here had you not push me it's a lemon
Claire do a grab job on our country
center company which was about to go
broke oh yeah and everything's so
fantastic me no witness my tragic moment
well this is the first alcohol I've had
since the baby's born and I gotta tell
you it feels right
Bon Appetit yeah well Mexican food is
spicy ease up on some water this is what
I do with my mama speaking milk there
you go there you go there you guys go
smell it's thick this is the first night
since I had writer that I washed my body
I did my hair I put on some makeup to
hang out with my girls instead of
staying home II what Cheerios stuck on
my baby's crevices and it's thick no
fuss
well well well is this what those Claire
Luna coins gets us hmm you don't have to
get us such fancy gifts but I love it we
wanted to it's a big moment for all of
us yeah we wouldn't be here without you
guys goochie goochie goo okay
so how are we gonna rebrand for Claire
what is our story I'm a divorced pet
lover
use mine Sydney love you love your story
but I think we should just stick with
our own story you know keep it real we
can't go back to Claire and tell her
what we've come up with this we're just
keeping it real we need to try something
new let's dish it up a little bit did
you just say geesh don't be so
judgmental
why is prefix way better than real sex
look let's play come when you want them
to girl that is so true when I've done
that I never think about all the stuff
we've done and wonder how we did not die
[Applause]
we are too bad as Queens like those
[ __ ] aways Wonder Woman we've worked
our asses off we've opened up our own
store we're women four hundred and
ninety-three thousand dollars in debt
[Music]
I'm Clara Luna I am going to invest 1.7
million dollars on you
but in my experience business and
friendship don't always mix you don't
have to worry your pretty little head my
head is not little it's just that my
breasts are humongous
you want to be a businesswoman you're
gonna have to act like a boss you have
to fire him
what don't hate me hate Mel was her
trying to you witness my tragic moment
[Music]
introducing a new product at her launch
party she just wants to steal our ideas
we don't break this [ __ ] punch that
[ __ ] in the face I would marry you if I
was in the coochie those furs they are
very spicy just a little sliver goes a
long way you peppers are really hot
[Music]